you know a lot of times I'll have
conversation with somebody and they'll
say Pat this thing is so difficult to do
you know this business is difficult to
become a millionaire is difficult but
you don't undersell this stuff that I
hear by now tell them listen the way I
view the level of difficulty of anything
to do is how few people in the world
have done it if only one person has done
it guess what it's difficult because
there's 7 billion people living in the
world if only ones then it is difficult
if 10 I've done it ok grit I'll give you
that argument it's difficult but if many
have done it it shouldn't be that
difficult I hear me out
I'm I ask you question I want you to
answer the first answer the first
thought that comes to man I want you to
answer about whether it's Facebook
YouTube Twitter wherever you see this
answer it below the first thought ok how
many million dollar homes you think
there are in America how many million
dollar homes you think there are in
America comment below eighty there's
three hundred thirty million people
living in America fifty states what do
you think a thousand maybe 10,000 maybe
twenty-six thousand how many million
dollar homes do you think there are in
America I'm curious let me explain to
you why I'm saying this
it's because I'm challenging how small
some people think and how big some
people think according to Zillow
according to Zillow calm in the state of
California there are eight point three
million units that you and I can own do
you know ten point six percent of them
are worth more than a million dollars
that means there are a million million
dollar homes just in the state of
California in New York seven point seven
percent of all the units houses you and
I can buy their million-plus in Hawaii
it's 11 plus percent in a small state of
Rhode Island
it's 5600 million-dollar homes in
Massachusetts it's 56,000 million-dollar
homes there are millions of
million-dollar homes in America so what
was your answer I'm curious whatever
your answer was some tells me it wasn't
that many you know why because you think
becoming a millionaire is very difficult
and it isn't not in America matter of
fact any word that there's the
opportunity to become a business owner
it ain't difficult you won't live in a
million dollar home look the biggest
difference between somebody who lives in
a million dollar home and somebody that
doesn't is they don't think it's a big
deal to live in a million dollar home
and the rest think it's a big deal let
me explain to what I mean by this I was
in Bakersfield yesterday two days I was
in Baker's when I was having a
conversation and somebody started but
you don't saw my life Pat my father was
an alcoholic
you know and this person said my mother
was bipolar and I grew up in a bad side
I hear people tell me in Chicago I grew
up in a bad part of Chicago terrible
parts of New York DC baltimore LA I mean
you just don't understand my upbringing
I was diagnosed with ADHD when I was in
my mother's womb but you don't know my
story my ex told me I'm a loser
my father said I'll never amount to
anything my mom said nobody will ever
marry me nobody I'm ugly that's what my
mother told me I don't have a 4-year
degree I think got a two-year deal back
guess what I filled a lot of my classes
in high school but I'm Hispanic but Pat
I'm black I'm Middle Eastern I'm white
all of those stinks you tell yourself
they're all excuses and if you buy them
you're right
and the rest who live in those
million-dollar homes they stop buying
those excuses that they themselves try
to sell themselves and other people in
their lives try to sell them look your
parents ain't perfect your ex ain't
perfect your friends ain't perfect ain't
nobody perfect they're upset and they
told you something that doesn't make it
a hundred percent accurate if you
believe it they're right this is my
challenge to you stop making the big
seems so big where it's so difficult
millions of people live in
million-dollar homes millions and
millions of people run successful
businesses so can you
you